dans votre livre vous pointez du doigt
le déclin de l'amour et des relations
sexuelles du désir après c'est vrai que
malheureusement certains aujourd'hui non
plus forcément le temps d'avoir des
relations sexuelles d'ailleurs certains
les gens écrivent dans leur agenda en
train de commenter la question part j'ai
un copain vous promet sa copie après est
ce que c'est si grave de considérer que
l'acte sexuel est une corvée
c'est là que c'est gratuit pardonnez moi
mais pour vous visiblement c'est un
petit point de corde et ont l'impression
que c'est pas une corvée mais c'est vrai
que ça prend beaucoup de temps en tout
cas je peux vous répondre que lorsqu'il
devient une corvée c'est un véritable
problème ça ne devrait pas le citer
yoplait est essentielle ouais mais
pourquoi ça c'est votre avis pourquoi
c'est à mon avis un avis qui est partagé
vous ces laborantins de la saf et ça
fait partie de la bonne santé du sol
humain sinon c'est pas un couple
d'amoureux c'est un analyste on peut
tout à fait éprouvé de l'amour est un
amour très profond et durablement sans
qu'ils aient sexualité ça existe
d'accord mais c'est assez rare
d'accord ça va damien denrée rare je
crois qu'il va falloir que vous le
preniez une telle consécration mais
effectivement parfois on peut aussi être
j'allais dire subir des injonctions
comme vous pouvez voir dans notamment
dans des magazines féminins ou autres
qui nous disent qu'en gros il faudrait
pouvoir faire l'amour six fois cette
fois dix fois par semaine non sinon on
ne serait pas un couple épanoui
là encore dans l'eau 106 me sens inverse
vo c'est à dire que il ya une injonction
à dire si vous n'êtes pas un couple
normal
si vous n'êtes pas l'amour de façon non
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça je
pense que ce qu'il faut éviter c'est la
programmation du sexe j'explique très
bien en main parce que effectivement
elle melon âge explique très bien dans
mon livre parfait je suis très douée
n'ont plus vraiment un excellent ami
voilà donc oui programme est simple
effectivement aujourd'hui les comme les
femmes ont énormément de charge mentale
c'est l'expression à la mode et bien
effectivement le sexe passe après et le
couple est oublié ce qui passe d'abord
sur les tâches
domestique c'est s'occuper des enfants
quand il y en a c'est s'occuper de soi
aussi
car l'amour c'est d'abord soin et en
attendant sauf à vouloir programmer
alors qu'il ne ferait pas programmée
absolument d'accord constamment
soreplast le rôle des femmes le divenah
une question je crois alors que vous
nous offrez dans l'introduction de votre
livre vous nous offrez donc une une part
dont un plaidoyer pardon sur la
libération de la femme qui est
inexorablement entraîné le déclin de
l'homme perd ce pilier familiale qui
donc se retrouve sans repères donc c'est
un peu à cause des femmes visiblement
qui ont pris trop de place dans la
société que les couples ne
fonctionnerait plus ce que vous pensez
que c'était mieux avant je dois tomber
cette question n'est pas arrivée de l
eelam la féministe de la bande à pointer
du doigt le côté un peu ce sera parce
que nous aurions abandonné l'homme tout
seul dans son coin pour aller travailler
pour revendiquer des droits et donc
c'est habile et bernie au combien
légitime car combien légitime sauf que
les hommes ont leur part là-dedans parce
que effectivement ils se sont laissés
entraîner dans un mouvement de
féminisation clair et net
et effectivement ils ont ils en sont
arrivés à perdre leur place
une placette passe-t-on ce qu'on
remarque en ce que je remarque dans les
thérapies de cook
c'est que il ya une véritable confusion
des rôles des places les positions entre
l'homme et la femme
mais c'est quoi par part de pardonnez
moi mais est ce que ça veut dire que
deviendraient les archaïques
il faudrait que l'on l'homme soit le
dominant le patron du couple et c'est là
justement parce que le rapport de force
j'enchaîne sur quelque chose le rapport
de force dans le couple même s'il est
naturel quand il devient trop important
il prend trop de place
il est toxique dakar dont il n'y a pas
de le rapport dominant-dominé pour moi
non retour un modèle parfait patriarcale
non plus car très bien très bien vous ai
dit très bien oui alors moi j'ai lu
votre livre avec mon mari et mon samedi
la veille avec jean pierre pernaut va
ouvrir grand les vacances vous lisez à
deux chacun une page
c'est l'amour mesure qu'on lisait votre
livre on se regarde et on s'est dit mais
on est un couple d'espacé reste alors
selon votre analyse sur son français
combien vous pensez qu'il ya des extra
terrestres comme nous car on est content
le durable durable qui vous aimer à la
folie passionnément le même amour qu au
début oui eh bien eh bien ça j'en parle
aussi c'est à dire que je peux très
honnêtement c'est mais de la même façon
qu'au début c'est tout à fait possible
ce qu'il faut c'est entretenir à mon
sens l'amour comme en entretien et le
désir et le désir commun on n'entretient
pas une question
bah oui voila je suis un entretien
l'amour et le déjà en un coup
premièrement en évitant par exemple le
rapport de force
ensuite en acceptant les différences
entre l'homme et la femme
d'accord et oui ça ce qui est
fondamental parce qu'aujourd'hui la
tendance et la parité l'égalité
tu es capable de faire enfin la femme
disant tu es capable de faire tout ce
que je peux faire
oui héééé rajoutant mais c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut le faire
mais non si tu fais pas bien à carbon
mais ça c'est des petits exemples mais
c'est accepter les différences de
l'autre et c'est véritablement sa une
des clés de la réussite du couple
d'accord voilà un nom aiderait bien à la
notte sait dompter donc vous pensez qu
il convient d sera terrestres
qu'extraterrestres non seulement vous
n'êtes pas unique n'a pas mal mais si on
sera sur le rapport sept sur dix qui
divorce et que ce soit oui voilà 70 % de
femmes qui demande le divorce
c'est sa voix la bombe à écouter ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va prendre
des petits coups quand même parce qu on
a envie quand même que le coupé durant
l'été c'est compliqué pour les couples
voit ce que l'été arrive là dont
j'aurais savoir faut se voir cause à
pouvoir recevoir faut que j'arrête de
bosser